exes in New York are just two of the
latest examples of violence against
religious groups President Trump called
anti-semitism an evil scourge Secretary
of State Mike Pompeo said it is tragic
and unacceptable for any nation to
pursuit persecute for religious beliefs
correspondent Julian Turner tonight
looks at the growing and disturbing
trend in the wake of the attack in
Muncie Jewish leaders are ringing alarm
bells about a dramatic rise in
anti-semitism not just in New York State
but nationwide
there's not your current of
anti-semitism that existed for some time
and for whatever reason you're seeing it
more and more prevalent and more out in
the open and it's scary and it's
obviously very sad 20:19 has seen an
alarming 1347 attacks targeting jews
carried out across the united states but
human rights advocates say it's not just
the number of attacks that are cause for
concern we're looking at an upward trend
in assaults meaning the more severe of
the types of incidents that we track and
now murder right so that's where we're
worried that we're climbing up that
pyramid of hate and we need to put a
stop to it to dampen down and stop it
because enough is enough
this weekend's attacks prompting
President Trump to denounce what he
calls the evil scourge of anti-semitism
Democrat congressman Eric's wall well
claiming anti-semitism is on the rise in
America and it's being stoked by at real
Donald Trump
congresswoman receded to leave accused
the president of igniting violence
tweeting quote he fuels people's anger
and misguided hate but Secretary of
State Mike Pompeo came to the
president's defense today telling Fox
News fighting religious persecution is a
top-tier priority for the administration
and has been from day one President
Trump has made a true pillar of
America's foreign policy religious
freedom the right of each of us to
practice our faith in the way that we
desire to do so and we work hard at this
Pompeyo also says it's not just Judaism
that's under renewed attack we've all
observed Christians under threat in the
Middle East and other parts of the world
as well I've talked at some length about
China and how it's persecuting over a
million Muslims in Xinjiang province the
Trump administration's top list of
violators of religious freedom around
the
world currently includes China Iran
North Korea and Saudi Arabia
looking ahead now to 2020 the trump
foreign policy team still working on a
new policy they say would make American
foreign aid contingent upon how well
countries treat their right largest
religious minorities the plans critics
though say it's just another political
gambit Mike to appease the president's
evangelical base Julian Turner thanks
very much